today Okajima brought a new death  stranding trailer to the game Awards and  of course there was more to it than  meets the eye  I'm Tony and this is your investigative  GameSpot news update the trailer  featured plenty of weirdness from  guillermo del toro carrying a baby in a  jar to tanks transporting fleshy eel  things to Mads Mikkelsen controlling  soldiers with tentacles then Kojima took  to Twitter to say that the trailer was  packed with hints and red herrings for  the game itself so did any of that  weirdness actually matter only time will  tell  but don't let that stop you from coming  through it for more clues we don't know  much about death stranding but it's  slated for a launch on ps4 and PC this  is the second trailer we've gotten this  year so expect more in the future to  keep up with Hideo Kojima and all of his  antics you're already in the right place  [Music]